[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america we're so glad you're
here george campbell ramsey personality
host of the fine print podcast which is
uh just finished its first season and
had a record record listening
listenership so thank you guys for
joining us on that if you haven't
listened through the fine print yet you
need to you can find it where anywhere
great podcasts are sold and they're free
and it's free by the way there you go
that's how that works open phones here
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five you jump out we'll talk about
your life your money uh fadio is with us
in norfolk virginia to start off this
hour hey fadio how are you
good how are you doing better than i
deserve how can we help
well um i
just recently found out that my plant
where i work is closing down i've been
here for 18 years
and i'm trying to figure out what i
should do with like my investments my
401ks and
all that type of stuff
i talk to a few different people and i'm
not sure
what route i should go what type of
mutual funds i should look at and things
like that wow
how old are you
50 54. okay okay cool
and so the how much money do you have in
your mutual funds are in your in your
401ks and retirement plans
uh
probably around 300 000.
way to go man good good for you
well i'm an everyday millionaire also
well good way to go man that's awesome
and where's the rest of the money
well i got a 500 000 worth of raw land
plus i got a that's paid for i got a 280
000 paid for house
and then i have another house that i
only hold about fifty thousand on and
that's worth about three hundred and
thirty thousand where'd it go man
well done well done so what are you
gonna do what's your next career step
um i have uh six special needs children
and
we're gonna the 100 acres i have is
going to be turned into a sustainable
farm i have three boys with autism and
we're gonna
raise cattle and
you know firewood businesses things like
that
okay and your your plan with that is to
make enough income to support the family
without having to touch these
investments
well my
my uh my wife is uh
she's she's got her own business she's a
behavioral analysis person
and she's getting ready to start her own
business and uh
we'll have probably close to 250 000 a
year household income
okay good for you and that's even after
you leave the plant
yeah okay that's great well that makes
this situation a lot less scary i mean
there's not a lot to fear here so you're
just wondering what you should do
financially or career-wise because you
were talking about the mutual funds
you're talking about just rolling your
300 over to mutual funds in an ira right
yeah i was i was
gonna do i'm gonna do a direct transfer
rollover but the other thing was uh the
company
uh we're with vanguard and vanguard is
offering a
no penalty fee
to do a payout where they would just
withhold the taxes
and then they would just give me a check
for the rest but not charge me any
penalties because i'm before 50 59 and a
half it's not up to vanguard
it's a law
is vanguard gonna give you 10
what they're gonna what they what they
would do is they would just withhold uh
whatever the taxable rate would be
and then they're not going to charge i i
guess they said there was no penalty fee
there is a penalty
because the company was closing there is
a penalty
oh okay so then whoever i talked to over
there and didn't know what they're
talking about that's you know that's the
i mean that doesn't go away
uh but you know and they they don't have
the power to waive it because it's not
their penalty it's the government's
penalty it's an irs
regulation so okay uh if they if they're
going to reimburse you which i doubt so
no anyway i'm not doing any of that you
don't need this money and you don't need
to pay it out i would get just get with
the smartvestor pro roll it all over
like you said a direct transfer rollover
into a traditional ira the four types of
mutual funds we talk about yeah you
diversify those across the four types
with that smart investor pro and that
money is going to grow i mean if you're
even looking at you know let's say 10
percent rate of return that's going to
give you some great money as you head
into retirement years without really
having to touch anything else any of
this property you're going to be a
multi-millionaire with that yeah well
done yeah growth growth and income
aggressive growth international the four
mutual funds i invest in and that we
teach people to that's what you're going
to do and just sit down pick those out i
just keep this real clean and real
simple the great news is you've done
such a good job building wealth that um
that like george said there's no fear in
this process it's kind of sad that the
plants going away
but um but now you get to go do the farm
thing with an encore career yeah the
farm thing with your kids and that's
going to be that's going to be a lot of
fun be a lot a lot of a lot of action
over there zach is in orlando zach
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you dave
um so i'm i'm curious to know when i
should start bridge investing i know
i've heard you mention it occasionally
but i just wanted to
understand where in the baby steps this
would fall bridge investing is for
having money to retire with or to feed
yourself with out of an investment uh
before 59 and a half
which means that's quote unquote
retiring early
so to speak okay
and so yeah you don't fool with that
till baby step seven that's additional
wealth is what that is
got it
how old are you
i'm 25. wow already thinking about this
that's great so i'm guessing you want to
retire early do you have any any goals
any vision for this
yeah my my goal is to retire about 40 to
45 or at least not have to worry about
um you know working and just do you know
do work for for fun basically so you
want a nasdaq big enough that you would
be able to retire 45 and still do
whatever you want without worrying about
bringing in new income you could
probably pull that off so do you not
like what you're doing
um i do i just want to you know be able
to invest
in my family and uh just just have that
financial freedom to really do whatever
i'm sure i'll still be working at some
in some capacity yeah so we're not
really talking about retiring and hating
your job and i can't wait to get away
and i'm 25 and i already hate no that's
not what we're talking about we're just
talking about you're gonna have some
wealth
um and so that's that's a good that's a
good plan brother that's good good that
you're thinking out that far ahead
george john uh dr dolony dr john delaney
and i were talking about this the other
day on the air that this word retirement
when you throw it around like this uh
it's even back to the chris hogan retire
inspired days where retirement's not a
uh not a not an age it's a number
and um it's not really retirement
i don't really teach people to retire
yeah uh if you if you hate your job and
you can't wait to retire you should
change jobs
you know
you should change careers you should do
something different you shouldn't be
handcuffed to to something you hate but
but to have wealth to give you options
now i'm all about that but people call
that in air quotes retirement
even though they're not going to retire
it's just you can do what you want to do
instead of what you have to do yeah that
that's exactly that's what he's a that's
what zach's aiming at yeah and uh so
you know i uh i haven't had to work
for many years so
i was able to not work which i guess is
what we're talking about right
but chose to work because i love what i
do matter of fact you all just can't get
rid of me so there you go you're here to
spread hate and ascension at this point
that's my job this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net and get 1000 to twenty
five hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
george rachel cruz and i will be doing a
big event next thursday night january
the 13th
it is building wealth in 2022.
the 1500 tickets we had for an in-room
uh yeah it's not a room that's a big
room but
in-house uh in person uh viewing sold
out in about 30 seconds so those are all
gone
and we've got about 70 000 folks
registered to view it by live stream
free
so it looks like we'll probably have
over a hundred thousand people watching
on the live stream at this point and you
don't want to miss this it doesn't cost
you a dime because i mentioned to you
it's free rachel cruz george campbell
we're going to talk about building
wealth this year in this current
environment and man there's some stuff
going on out there
there's so much out there as i'm looking
at what articles what people are talking
about they're not really as concerned
with solving the root problems like
getting out of debt and having an
emergency fund they're trying to bring
an income as quickly as possible and
what that leads them to is these get
rich quick schemes and they start
getting advertisements for courses on
tick tock and instagram and facebook
with big promises to make them money
instantly that's scary
yeah that's that is scary it's wild so
anyway we'd love to have you watch this
with us it's gonna be a couple hours
long it'll be george
campbell rachel cruz dave ramsey talking
about building wealth in 2022 it is free
to watch it as a live stream and again
it's sold out so it's your only option
free to watch it is a live stream
thursday january 13th you do have to
pre-register and we will send you the
link for you to do this free so go to
ramseysolutions.com
slash wealth ramsey solutions dot com
slash wealth
bob's in traverse city michigan hi bob
what's up
hey dave how are you better than we
deserve man how can we help
thank you hey i'm curious i
i own a home um it's a brand new home i
actually lost it to a fire almost two
years ago
rebuilt had to refinance
they appraised the home at 600 000 just
before construction was done
my dilemma is my dad's farm my dad's
retired
i am trying to decide
if i should sell my home
buy my dad's farm or finance my dad's
farm
um at my place i have two rentals on the
property already
that pay all but 200 of the mortgage
payment
my dad's place has one rental
and then the farmhouse that he rents out
as well so there's already two rentals
there
my long-term goal is to have five
rentals out there there's different lots
so my long-term goal is to put in more
homes and have rentals and be able to
live off that income when i retire
so i'm in a big dilemma to sell my place
and pay cash or what i do
okay uh how old are you
42. how many acres is the farm
farm is 80 acres and my home is 20 acres
okay so you would live on the farm if
you sold your home
if i sold my home i would remodel the
farmhouse and i would live it i would
live there and then down the road is
where the rentals are so they're not
close to my home are you married
no okay all right
nobody talking about three children
you ain't anybody talking into this
three children
at home
no one's out of the home 117 and the
other one's 12. okay
all right so i'm curious if you sold
your place
how much money would that give you to
put to the farm you said you could do it
with cash
i could i owe just under 240 on my home
okay so you'd be making about 300 and
some change there
what do you what do you make a year
oh about 95 a year how much other money
have you got
i've got probably about 120 000 in
savings
[Music]
well i just i always dial these things
back to kind of and i have to do it in
about 30 seconds here what would i do if
i woke up in your shoes i'm going to be
debt free you know you called dave
ramsey right
and so you know that's going to happen
and for me to go into debt to buy rental
property which is in effect what you'd
be doing
i'm not going to suggest you do that i
want you to get rental property but i'm
not going to suggest you do it with debt
i never have in 30 years here on the air
and i don't guess we'll start today so
um
you know as i think through it it
doesn't sound really scary either way
but what would i do
uh i would sell it and i would pay cash
for the farm and then i'd start using
all of the any cash flows i can create
to build the first property and build
another property and build another
property and or buy other properties
that are rentals
um i think you're going to want some
rentals that are not next door i think
that's not not a bad idea
because renters that are next door
uh it's um both good and bad they'll
come knocking yeah they could come
knocking and you have to set a different
an additional set of relational
boundaries with them in that
but the good news is you can find them
if you need to um you just walk over
there but uh
but it's a uh uh
you know it's a mixed bag in that sense
so but yeah pay cash
it sounds like he's got this vision for
the farm that he's excited about which
is great but again if you move at the
speed of cash it gets a lot less scary a
lot less risk yeah and and again i i it
has served me so well for 30 years
living my life that way after i went
broke in real estate to just pay cash
and i mean it just simplifies everything
i don't i don't i don't have the
debt option on the table and so
if i'm gonna buy something i just have
to look and see if i have the money it's
that simple and uh and then i don't have
any payments if there's a pandemic oh
that never happens though okay open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five trey is with us in
colorado springs hey craig trey what's
up
i had a career question for you guys how
are you guys doing today great man how
can we help
um so
i
have a career option that i'm looking at
that would
increase my income by
about two and a half times the amount it
is now but uh it'd be an oilfield job so
it would involve me being away from my
daughter and my wife uh frequently i
mean it'd be like two weeks on and two
weeks off
um
and it'll speed up we did the math uh
we're on baby step two right now um
we've got 19 000 left and it would
speed that up by about seven months and
then funding our emergency fund it would
speed up by
uh i mean overall it would knock a whole
year off of the thing and uh it's a big
change and i'm trying to make sure that
i am looking at the whole picture and
i'm getting uh a good
i want to make sure i'm not making a
mistake and i'm not overlooking anything
important in a career change like that
and i was hoping to get your guys kind
of opinion on that
well you know the oil field that's
that's some hard work and of course the
pay comes with that so this feels like
it's a short-term thing i don't know
that i could do this long term and the
year you know speeding your your debt
snowball and the baby steps up by a year
i don't know that that's tantalizing
enough for me to jump on because of how
big of a move this is being away from
the family uh so if that's something you
and your and your wife decide this is
the right move for us to do this then
i'm good with it knowing that it's
probably not going to be the long term
thing for the next 10 15 years
what do you do now
that was kind of um so so i do
electrical right now and it'd be
electrical on the oil rigs as well
another factor that kind of plays into
it we've been trying to do the math of
when it comes to baby step 3b of how
long it would take us to save up a down
payment and where i am right now um i
mean unless i open my own company i'm
pretty close to kind of maxed out and
we don't see us being able to purchase a
home here in this area
at any time soon whereas this would also
speed that up and make that a
possibility how old your baby
she will be eight months old next week
what's your wife say about all this
um
she's hesitant about it because she
doesn't necessarily want me gone but at
the same time she agrees that it would
be something not necessarily forever but
uh so if you do it for six months and
you decide it ain't worth it and you
want to come home can you come home
can you land back on something
yeah yeah definitely so there's very
little downside to trying it
that's kind of that's kind of what i was
looking at but uh i mean it's i've never
done anything like this and i was trying
to make sure you know i'm not
it's almost uh
i don't want to bite off more than i can
chew i guess without really thinking of
all the repercussions that comes with it
i guess that makes sense that's very
wise i appreciate that
i don't see anything that's scaring me i
will tell you we work with the military
a lot and when one of the spouses is
deployed
a lot of financial mistakes are made
in the name of i'm tired i'm lonely i'm
away
if you don't have a very set plan on
what you're going to do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today john and ashley from
colorado springs are on the line says on
my screen you guys are debt-free
congratulations
thank you thanks dave well done how much
did you pay off
209 089
way to go and your range of how long did
this take you
uh four years four years in your range
of income during that time
145 to 200 000. cool what do you guys do
for a living
so i am a pharmacist that works in
administration
and i'm a medical laboratory scientist
oh wow
a couple of smart people
well done what kind of debt was this 209
000 i'm guessing pharmacy school
yeah you'd be right and added with some
stupid on there okay and a vehicle a
vehicle and student loan debt and what
else
uh that was it oh that's all 189 000
student loan and the rest was a van whoa
okay
how long you guys been married
nine years
okay so you've been bopping along four
or five years in marriage and you look
up and say
209 thousand this is not fun anymore
tell me the story what got you started
what's what lit you on fire for this
ramsey stuff
so you know how you always well the
bible says the borrow borrower is um
slave to the lender
and john's actually a veteran and we had
to get out of the army
even though he wanted to stay in because
you know with me needing to work and pay
back those massive student loans i had
to have a job so
it kind of made some life decisions for
us and and even though i made a budget
every month we didn't stick to it um
so so yeah we it made some life
decisions we had to get out of the army
and uh get steady and decided to attack
it from there
wow oh okay
so uh so in civilian life you make more
than you did in the military john
yeah that's right okay all right and and
of course actually he's gonna use the
pharmacy degree and move on and you guys
are making money like that's how the 145
to 200 happens right
yep
okay that forced you to address this how
did you get connected to us
so you know we grew up in church and
we'd always heard your name um you know
and when
it got overwhelming i just started
listening to your youtube channel
and um you know kind of got direction
from there we were we were too cheap to
pay for the classes so we just kept
listening to your youtube every day um
and that's how we got started that's
awesome that's all the motivation you
needed with some youtube videos
very it was we had debt-free screams on
repeat every saturday morning when we
were cleaning the house wow i love it
that's fun just sit and listen to them
over and over different ones that's
great yep very very cool and that also
ends up giving you enough instruction to
know how to work your way through this
right
yep exactly so 209 000 paid off in four
years what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
well we really think that there's two
keys and we'll keep it brief but one is
putting god first and i i think that's a
nice phrase but you actually have to put
it into practice so pray over the
budgets and and really commit it to god
and know that you're doing it for god
and he really blessed those efforts
and we became thankful and content it
grew those seeds in our hearts and i
think that's key
especially when you're going intense for
four years you need that and the second
one is like i said we did a budget for
years and we didn't stick to it and that
doesn't do anything so you actually have
to follow the roadmap
wow
i love that insight yeah doing a budget
is one thing actually
sticking to it that's the hard part yeah
that's
exactly right a little bit of faith a
little bit of contentment and a whole
lot of budgeting
oh yeah
that's incredible so do you guys have
any cheerleaders along the way did
people think you were weird for doing
this stuff
so
pretty much everybody was supportive
but there were a lot of people who
questioned specific things that we did
and just thought it was really weird
that's how you know you're on on the
right path
yeah well one of those things that
people said that's weird why would you
do that
yeah right he cut my hair we re-roofed
our house on our own we sold a nice car
and bought a you know old beater
those sorts of things our kids kept
telling they were our biggest
cheerleaders honestly our six-year-old
told everyone that we were on a budget
and that's why he couldn't have his
happy meal
you know unless we put it in the budget
um but he was so excited to be debt-free
so that's really probably our biggest
cheerleader true happiness fun that's
great
dave would sharon uh let you cut her
hair
no okay just curious no
and nor would i nor would i attempt that
i i do not have uh that is not among the
gifts that i even approach that's one of
the first times i've heard that level of
sacrifice so i i applaud you guys how
did the haircut turn out
uh i have uh actually two sayings that
summarize my philosophy of cutting hair
you wanna hear them sure
so the first one comes from my dad it's
uh do you wanna keep the ears
i like that
and uh the second one is the difference
between a bad haircut and a good haircut
is two weeks
oh that's good
well based on the photos we're seeing on
the screen here uh the haircut looks
good so great
it
any photos with uh john messing up
that's for sure
well if you mess up it just gets shorter
[Laughter]
he's figured it out
this guy's got this guy's got a future
i'm just saying a lot of one-liners
probably not
well worth it
well done you guys very well done we're
very proud of you you're very impressive
how's it feel now that you're done
it's great freedom it's like a weight
lifted off our shoulders i mean when you
think that our payments were you know
2700 a month um i mean that's just huge
a huge chain that's been broken kind of
unbelievable
yeah it's a different different
you feel like you lost 300 pounds i mean
it's crazy
oh for sure it's just amazing so very
well done you guys very well done you
all are rock stars that's fun absolutely
amazing you know the former military guy
does the haircuts this that just
occurred to me
now what do you get here high and tight
right that's a nice shave yeah okay
yeah pretty much
oh my gosh
all right john and ashley in colorado
springs 200 oh wait we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires coming out next
week we'll send it to you immediately
and you'll get it about the time it
comes out probably something like that
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away and disturb
someone's life that'll be awesome so
very cool stuff john and ashley colorado
springs 209 000 paid off in four years
making 145 to 200 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well done you guys
very well done
now hair cutting was not one of the
things that uh for sharon that we uh did
in-house i i don't have any hair so
mine's really easy i've been i've been
to a barber shop in years save a lot of
money that way yeah i just got to talk
about these little clippers over at
sam's club and just
about once a week and it pretty well
keeps it and and i don't have any
shampoo cost either so it's um silver
lining to being to be i'm just saying
i'm just saying it's real low
maintenance don't i don't have to worry
about getting hair and makeup done
i mean we get makeup done when i'm doing
a shoot of course but but you got the
hair i mean you have the you don't want
to know what it is a lot a lot of effort
goes in it takes a village and a lot of
pomade to make this happen
but you know
oh village of oompa loompas running
around the grass is always greener on
the other side
but you don't have much grass
whoa
not a lot of lawn care that's all i'm
saying that's all i'm trying to say no
weed eater needed yeah
what i love about john and ashley and it
made me think about this what are you
willing to do yeah
and they were willing to do just about
anything and get creative with it i mean
they thought we can save 200 have you do
you know how much it costs to get a
woman's haircut you know what it costs
i mean they roof their own house it's
impressive that's uh yeah pretty pretty
amazing it's those kinds of sacrifices
they were too cheap to buy to buy
financial peace university even i mean
so just watching you just going too far
right there yeah
that's all right that's all right we're
happy to do it
i'm glad they got out of debt that's so
awesome it's very fun yeah you really do
you have to ask yourself what am i
willing to not do is as important as
what i am willing to do
in order to hit your goals and uh
that usually keeps people from hitting
their goal whatever their goal is
more than the thing they're willing to
do yeah if you're saying what am i
willing to cut out what am i willing to
add in and start doing man you'll start
to get excited about what could happen
changes a lot of stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print podcast is my co-host
today david is in phoenix arizona hi
david welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
uh so i recently finished nurse practice
from school and i'm gonna be moving into
that role here in the next month or so
i'm sorry i didn't understand you your
phone's kind of weird are you speaking
directly into it what did you say you
finished what
i recently finished nurse practitioner
school oh good and i'm gonna be moving
into that role here in the next month or
so cool
um but by doing that um i'll be joining
a doctor's group that they contract you
out as a 1099 employee so they don't
offer any health insurance or any
benefits but then of that sort so
my question was is i've been looking at
different options and i know you guys
endorse christian healthcare
um and ministries
looking at their plans and planning on
going that with that but i saw that they
cap out at a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars for
per event so
i'm just trying to figure out if that's
still the best way to go or if i should
look at
private insurance which i know is
usually quite a bit more expensive we
don't really have any major
health problems with our family so we're
pretty healthy as far as that goes but
i do know that any like major
hospitalization typically
um is quite a bit more than that so i
just want to get your input on that
exactly exactly well that's the obvious
risk
that you're taking with a cap on that
and um
uh we do know that uh 100
of the claims
or the uh the
effectively what we would call claims
out here
have been paid by that company over the
years and so we trust them in that
regard uh full disclosure i'm not on it
george is not on it uh we have uh
you know a group health policy here at
ramsey and we're both a part of that
um and so
and of course you know the company pays
the vast majority of that for our our
team members so it's it's less
less expensive out of georgia's pocket
than christian healthcare would be
because he's not in the open market like
you are
so um right but uh you know i'm real
careful to make sure that everybody
knows what i you know i don't i don't
endorse something i wouldn't do or or
don't believe in enough to send
my my mother there that kind of a thing
right you know so
uh uh
that's the way we feel about uh chm
they've been with us for many many years
as an indoor as a as a sponsor and we
don't sponsor just anyone uh over the
years we've had different companies go
broke and different things
that
didn't follow through on things when we
were sponsoring i mean when they were
sponsoring and we were endorsing them
it's embarrassing when that happens but
it's not our fault we don't cause it but
we never
we try to be as careful as we can to put
our name on something so yeah i believe
in them i believe in what they're doing
um i know the guys that run it i've had
meetings with them uh and um i think
they'll do exactly what they said they
were gonna do but you're obviously
tuned in to the biggest part of the risk
and you just gotta decide if you wanna
take that extra risk
yeah i'm in the same boat as dave here
and on top of that i would add health
insurance is very personal and so as
you're looking into this you know you
can jump onto ramsey solutions and uh
click on trusted there and you can
connect with an insurance agent who is
not tied to any one company and they'll
shop around to find the best possible
health insurance for you at the best
price for what your family's needs are
so that would be my first step is to do
that and then weigh it against christian
healthcare ministries talk it over with
with your family and again
health insurance is all about risk how
much risk are you willing to take on and
then your premiums will reflect that
yeah and um and of course we all you
know know technically
speaking uh chm is not technically
insurance it's technically a sharing
program
uh but it's filling the gap of what
insurance would have done if you don't
if you don't have insurance or don't
choose to go with traditional health
insurance so
no no apologies for endorsing them proud
to endorse them lots of people that are
ramsey listeners use them and have good
experience uh so no problems with any of
that but that's that's the whole ups and
downs of the thing good good people
involved steve is with us steve's in
lansing michigan hi steve how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
okay uh well my wife and i are uh what
seemed seems like an impossibly tight
spot uh we've uh we've been dealing with
uh
basically uh increasing health problems
and income reduction
and right now we're kind of in a spot
where we feel like we need
uh you know like an unrealistic
financial miracle that we know won't
happen
uh so that that's kind of the situation
where i ran
okay let's talk that through and
understand what you're talking about
okay what is your insurance what are
your incomes
okay um we we were at about 74 30 a
month and it is we have been reduced to
about 3 200. i'm a paraplegic i've
always worked
but my work has completely dried up over
this past year with kovid and a few
things and then her income was reduced
and she has lost her health insurance so
like i said we go from 74 30 to 3 200 a
month
we've had some big home and vehicle
repairs that are necessary you know
we're going through total money makeover
we realized that we weren't there for
that so we
kind of dialed it back and we're going
through financial peace
and
we realized we're still not even quite
there so we really need some direction
on what to do with this situation
so what are you doing for work right now
uh right now i'm a freelance web
developer
and
technology and
kind of a small business uh small
business has been my main clientele and
that has largely evaporated could you
look for a salaried
with a company i
yes yeah i'm i'm in the process of
trying to do that i am not
i have not been successful uh thus far
with that
okay
help me with this because web developers
are in great demand
when you say you're a web developer what
do you what do you mean you're a dev1
dev2 dev3
what are your platform architect what do
you do
yeah i do yeah i
basically i just do
i'm kind of a jack-of-all-trades i am uh
i do
i create
sites for you know small businesses i
work with their marketing i do
just try to to set up uh
new businesses with an entire
just their entire initial setup do you
have the skills to join a dev team
probably not okay that's what i was
hearing probably not to be honest okay
all right
because that obviously the dev the bit
the developer world is is just in great
demand right now we've got a
several hundred of them on our team and
and they're constantly hiring in that
spot and so that's the only reason i've
got a little bit of knowledge about it
is it's a frustration point here at
ramsey so uh if but if you can
so you really need to get your business
moving of helping small businesses or
get involved with somebody who's doing
that like a marketing agency or
something that would hire you to help
with the with the technology side of a
marketing campaign
yeah so yeah something like that would
would be would be wonderful i've had
a big private like i said there's uh
what were you doing who were you with
before how were you how were you making
money before
word of mouth
online
uh
just some some small online marketing uh
and just you had multiple clients
yes
yes
okay were they in a space that were shut
down with covet or what
yeah um yeah
i had four major i wouldn't say major my
four primary clients and all of them uh
dried up over the course of the last
year and a half
okay every single one shot down there
okay all right
well the good news is you're not
geographically bound with what you're
doing you could do it you you can reach
out online and you could be doing it for
someone in nashville you could be doing
it for someone i mean if lansing's not
operating as openly as some other areas
you could get that going so i think
you've got a marketing problem on your
side and and you're probably your
miracle in that regard how much of the
7430 were you making
uh
let's see 74
um hold on
i got my numbers here probably
over half
there's about 40
let's see
32 okay i was about 42. yeah it feels
like you guys have an income crisis that
is creating these other crises
and just in talking to you for a moment
here that's what it feels like and it
feels like you guys got to get
uh
you you've had all these things happen
to you and you've got to turn the tables
and start happening to
the situation let me send you a copy of
ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose
and jump on his website start studying
things i'll also send you a copy of the
entree leadership book since you're
running your own thing because i really
want to give you guys a boost on the
income side of the equation i think
that's going to solve where you're going
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
fine print podcast is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
work your relationships your money and
your life that's what we're here for
common sense
for your life common sense is so rare in
america today it's like having a
superpower
so we're here to help you triple eight
eight two five five two two five jacob
starts off this hour in chattanooga hi
jacob welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up man
so my wife and i are 27 we've been in
our home for
about a year and a half now but we've
just been listening to your show for
about a year
so we're trying to figure out if we
should refinance our home from a 30 year
to 15
um based on where we are right now
no
if you pay a 30 like a 15
it pays off in 15.
now you would refinance it either way
and while you're at it put it on a 15 if
you can save enough on the interest for
that to make sense yeah and what we talk
about with refinancing is doing a break
even analysis which just means figuring
out when you're going to roi on this
decision so what's your current interest
rate
um 3.5 3.5 on the 30 year what would you
go down to if you did the 15
um
i think it would just barely bump down
if not stay the same
yeah no no it'd be more like 2.5 right
now
i mean the rates this week on 15 will be
around two and a half so you save around
one percent what's your balance
120 okay
all right
so if you save one percent that's 1200
bucks
a year
if the refinance cost is 3 600 bucks it
takes three years to recoup that's what
george talking about of a of a break
even analysis if you're saving twelve
hundred dollars and
but if you're saving twelve hundred
dollars it takes twenty four hundred
dollars to refinance then you recoup in
two years you're following me
yep i got you but you don't have to do
any of that you can run those numbers
out if you want with churchill mortgage
and see where you stand
it's borderline i doubt it's going to
make sense i would imagine your closing
costs are going to make this break even
too far out to make it to make it fun
with with the spread that you've got uh
because it might not be two five it
might be 275 which changes it from 1200
down to about 900 and now it gets less
you know lengthens that break even time
out there you don't want to break even
time much more in two years
it doesn't make sense so the
the answer to big answer your question
is you don't have to refinance just to
go to a 15. you just start get your
calculator out and your your payment
calculator at ramseysolutions.com and do
the payment on 120 000 at three
and a half percent on 15 years
and then through the payment principal
interest only at three and a half figure
out what your exact principal and
interest is
and then the difference you pay that as
extra principal every month which is
making you basically pay a 15-year
payment you see what i'm doing
yeah that's what i mean and it pays off
in exactly as if you've done a 15-year
yeah and a lot of people dave you know
obviously we recommend only getting a
15-year if you've already done the 30
that's okay it's usually not worth
undoing that decision unless you have an
unusually high interest rate or there's
some other factors at play but
i love the spirit of it i can tell that
you guys want to do this plan so the
best thing you can do is start to make
double triple mortgage payments and get
that thing paid off in 15 years or less
yeah because here's the thing you're not
really going to run that extra 15 very
long if you're working the baby steps
because when you get to baby steps four
five and six you're putting 15 of your
income away to retirement you're doing
kids college and then any extra you have
you're throwing at the mortgage it's not
just the 15-year upgrade right and so
the 15-year upgrade would only apply
while you're working
uh one through
uh three and i might not even do it then
i'll probably just use that to work one
through three and just let it sit at 30
if you're if you're there so uh
you know that
so you really never actually do this
because you're gonna put more than the
extra upgrade in baby step six when
you're working baby step six
so stephen is with us steven is in
charlotte north carolina hi stephen how
are you hey i'm doing well dave thanks
for taking my call sure what's up
i am well let's see i'm trying to
navigate uh
home ownership in a living situation as
a what will be a newly married couple
i'm engaged yeah wonderful woman
i'll be getting married in september
i'm glad you didn't even get engaged to
a woman that wasn't wonderful
i know people that do that
that sounded close to home there man
[Laughter]
but uh so we're trying to navigate what
our living situation is going to be so i
am 31 i'm on baby step 3
i should be able to get there by about
march or april
she is also debt-free
um
and so between my 401k and our paid off
cars we'll be at about a six-figure net
worth when we get married wow but we
won't quite have what i would like for a
down payment for a house
and we're getting a lot of pressure from
family that oh well you can just get a
first-time homeowners loan and just put
3.5 down and we can have a you know walk
into a brand new house as a newly
married couple in september
um
and i'm getting a lot of pushback on
well you don't want to rent you'll be
throwing your money away and you know if
anything goes wrong my you know my dad
runs a heating and air company and i got
an uncle that's a plumber and she's got
family that has experience so i'm
getting this well hey don't worry about
needing all of this savings because if
something goes wrong you'll have family
support which is kind of good to know
but also
it's good that they're willing to put up
it's good that they're willing to put up
money because they're definitely
managing your life i was going to say
are they going to be paying your
mortgage because if so they don't get to
speak into this
yeah well that's and that's where i'm at
how do i push back against that because
i just smile you just smile and know
that there's people in your family that
don't agree with you welcome to being
married
gotcha okay
yeah it's and it's not it's it's my side
of the family and the in-laws so yeah
yeah it's not just pressure from one
direction
listen they don't get a vote
yeah they mean well but they don't
really get a vote because they're not
unless they're paying for it they don't
get a vote and they're not paying for it
yeah so you know i appreciate that and
you know what i don't disagree with your
heart and i don't disagree with that but
right now what we're gonna do is we're
just gonna do this and
and and you know well i don't well i
don't you know i'm sorry you don't but
that's okay or that's what we're doing
and just you know you just smile be kind
and do what you want to do and you're
not going to change their minds and
they're not going to change your mind so
you just got to move forward with your
plan so what i wouldn't do if i was in
your shoes stephen is i think the two of
you spend the first year of your married
life getting to know each other
don't spend time screwing with the house
just pouring out and that's it that's
that's you trust me i'd love to own a
house there's a lot i'm excited about i
i i don't want you to not own a house i
just don't want you to own one the first
12 months of your marriage i want you to
spend that 12 months on your marriage
pour into the relationship and here's
the thing that'll happen okay you're
going to have a lot more money is a good
strong down payment you're going to feel
comfortable with what you're doing and
you're going to make a different house
choice one year after marriage than you
will while you're engaged
because you know each other more and
you've talked it through and we've
planned this and we've looked at open
houses and went to new housing tracks
and talked about the features and things
we wanted and you dream together and
you know you'll build that house 63
times in your head and
you'll just make a better choice
that's what you need to do man
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
wow it is coming uh just a couple of
days from now the new book baby steps
millionaires will be out if you want to
learn how to be a millionaire using the
baby steps like tens of thousands have
done we're going to give you the exact
process we've already given you the
process we're going to give it to you
again but we're going to prove it to you
with like math and stuff
and with the data from the research and
with stories i'm excited about this book
it's the first book i've done in eight
years um i did not intend to do another
book major trade book like this uh but
we just kept seeing this uh thing in the
market where people were walking around
all these hope steelers were stealing
people's hope telling them you can't you
can't win today and i don't like hope
steelers george i punch hope steelers in
the nose they're right up there with
dream killers for you yeah they're hope
steelers dream killers they're like
brothers and sisters or something or or
dysfunctional cousins kissing cousins
yeah whatever yeah that kind of that's
kissing cause dysfunctional cousins i'm
excited are you gonna wake up a little
pep in your step on tuesday morning i
got i got it right now i mean i'm
excited about it in the event you and i
and rachel are doing on thursday night
i'm excited about it it's it's uh this
is a good
message
of hope which is what we do here that's
what you read on the headlines dave
everyone's so hopeful yeah it's so much
hope out there in america no cynicism at
all so we we i just love putting this
out there and just uh pushing some of
the trash aside that's go that's in the
headlines and some of the toxicity of in
people's voices and the lack of hope and
uh you know we're stuck and we can't get
here
i can show you otherwise okay
this is the non-whining book is what it
is so baby steps millionaires audio book
and ebook is included if you pre-order
the book before tuesday when it comes
out so you've just got a little bit of
time to do this we're also going to
throw in the legacy journey audiobook
and e-book we're also going to throw in
the ramsey smart tax filing for your
federal income tax filing we're going to
throw in 30 days
of ramsey plus which puts you in into
financial peace university and into um
every dollar premium all of that is
there and it's all it's about 150 worth
of goodies uh you don't want to miss all
this go ahead and get the pre-order on
the book because you're going to order
it next week anyway you might as well
get it from us and get it right now 20
bucks it's the best deal and you get all
these hundreds of dollars worth of stuff
so get it all at ramseysolutions.com
and we will be um you know be ready to
go monday with uh bells on screaming and
yelling about this book coming out next
week and just excited it's been a really
really fun process and
um
you know doing a book is a tough thing
but it's it's a lot of work but uh but
this one is just this is just from the
time we started it it's it's got
something on it so
pick it up baby steps millionaires at
ramseysolutions.com our question of the
day comes from blinds.com
a great american company with a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee
even if you screw up you miss measure
you pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds free you get free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
always use the code ramsey and you'll
get extra special deals yeah don't miss
out that's magic ramsey put that in the
promo code
today's question comes from shania in
new york i'm 25 years old and just
finished graduate school with some
student loan debt i landed my dream job
as a mental health therapist and earn
about 47 000 per year i live at home
with my mom and siblings and my mom
wants to move to north carolina next
year for cheaper housing costs i
personally don't want to go because i
don't want to leave my job but i'm
worried about the financial struggle i
could face when moving out on my own i
could afford it but it would be tight
would it be foolish for me to stay and
find a place here when north carolina is
so much cheaper i'm really conflicted
here and would appreciate your advice
well
shania you're 25 years old you're a big
girl i would live on your own regardless
of where you end up and if you love new
york i would stay in new york and if
it's tight it's tight your income's
going to go up
and you should be able to afford
something there but if you are just in
love with north carolina you want to be
close to family and you can find a job
over there that's an option too but i
would not base this on where mom is
going
yeah shania you don't need to go to
north carolina
not because north carolina's bad and not
because you don't need to go to north
carolina but the only reason that north
carolina is on the table is you have to
follow your mommy
and you don't need to follow your mommy
you're like a grown woman and stuff
so time for you to be that
hey welcome to adulthood we're glad
you're here
karen is with us karen is in new york
city hi karen how are you
hi dude it's corrine i'm sorry it's
karen isn't it
yes so i have a question my mom my mom
is 62 she's on survivor benefits
with social security you know she's
working part time 28k a year
but she lives with us she does with my
family my kids at our place but she
really wants her own place and she's
breaking out in highs because you know
she feels like she wants to be on her
own she's living on her own for so long
but she got laid off
and
now she needs her own place but she has
a retirement account about 180k
in there but she sees that as her death
benefit she doesn't have life insurance
so she's saying that's her death benefit
no it's not it's her life benefit
right
that's what i'm telling her but she's
she doesn't want to touch the money
so i'm just want to know what what are
her options to get her own place touch
the money
right
it's time
i mean you know
this is so inconsistent i'm breaking out
in hives because i want to live on my
own so much because i have a broken view
of this money
her job is not to leave you with an
inheritance her job is to not be a
burden
right
and
she's conflicted between these two
things because she's put too much of a
premium on leaving you an inheritance
what you guys have got to do spend some
time mom
mom
we're fine
right if you leave us your smile
you did your job
exactly
but the other thing is she she's she's
only making 28k a year and no one's
giving her an apartment for 28k a year
well you guys are in new york city
yep
it's so expensive and the basement
but she had a she had a better paying
job oh
doing what
she was working at adt
doing what
um admin
okay
admins in new york pay a lot better than
28k what the flip she doing now
well she was getting about 60k i know
they do a lot better than 28k in new
york she's doing home health aide now at
28k on this part time
part-time is she able to work full-time
sure
she is but she's also
watching our kids no she's not she's
going to get a new job
right you got to deal with your own kids
right
this woman is trying to do too many
things yeah she is doing a lot
especially she's trying to leave an
inheritance and she doesn't have the
money
she's trying to take care of your kids
instead of getting her own job because
she's only 62. right
so there's too many stuff got too much
stuff going on she's a very sweet person
is the problem yeah and she wants to be
everything to everybody and you need to
let her uh you guys need to have some
real frank you and your husband with
holding her sweet little hands and your
sweet little hands look into her eyes
and let her loose from some of these
responsibilities
yeah
so she's seen rent or buy a house rent
right
now she not buying anything for 180 in
new york city
that's sure
i don't i don't want a bunch of debt
she's 62.
yeah that's true so let's get her let's
get her back into the 50 000 to 60 000
job being grandma on nights and weekends
and out of your house and if she needs
to use a little bit of this money to
make the transition whoop-de-doopty
and she may need to move a little
further out from the city
get her with her smartvestor pro on the
180 and let's get that creating an
income it ought to create 15 or 20 000 a
year in income
right and she could do that and not even
touch the nest egg that would help a
bunch too
so let's uh let's she needs to resign
from some of her jobs
the i'm going to leave an inheritance
job the i'm the full-time babysitter job
and the i'm not going to use my money
job
the and get a new job making more money
than she makes at her bad job she is now
there's a lot of quitting jobs here
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the podcast the fine print on ramsey
networks first season is in the books
you need to go listen to the season
there's what 10 11 episodes 11 episodes
total we got a bonus one in there there
you go so be sure and check those
episodes out and uh we are planning now
and white boarding where george is going
to expose where the fine print is
screwing you next we just did the uh we
got the research back we did a survey a
thousand of you
did that survey for us thank you so much
for that and we got some great feedback
on what people are interested in what
they want to learn about and the words
that kept coming up were this was
informative this was honest this was
truthful this was funny this was
entertaining so we we hit the marks on
that side so we're really excited to dig
in some new topics for season two and
help people avoid a lot of the traps
that are out there yeah i agree with all
that it is all of that so go be sure and
check it out if you haven't already
the fine print great podcast
for you to check out at ramsey networks
it's uh again everywhere great podcasts
are sold josh is with us in virginia
beach hi josh welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
hey um i have a question about long-term
disability insurance um my wife stays
home with our one-year-old and she
currently has a policy but we think the
premiums are too expensive for the
benefit we're getting so i want to get
your take on that
okay
it's usually difficult to get disability
insurance on someone that does not have
an income
and that's part of the whole question so
she got the policy before she stayed
home she was working outside the home
has since stayed home with our
one-year-old
um what was she doing what was she doing
for a living
she was a physician assistant
okay
because disability pricing a lot of
times has as much to do with occupation
as it does with age or health
so it's a little bit it's a little bit
unusual in other words a window washer
high-rise window washers disability is
much much higher than someone who pushes
paper around a cubicle
sure and and even if they're the same
age and the same health and so
uh
you know that's the kind of thing you
may be running into have you priced it
with some other like gone to ramsey
solutions.com with some elps and done a
pricing run on it
so like you said because she's not
working outside the home anymore she's
not going to qualify to get a new policy
but we have this old policy still in
effect yeah how much is it
so the thing is where the benefit on it
is 1500 a month but we're paying 85 a
month premium
it almost seems to me like we could just
self-insure through a 1500 a month hit
if she were to become disabled i would
yeah okay
yeah that was uh
that's pretty steep
um i was 90 sure i just wanted someone
else's take on that yeah there is
actually some policies you can get now
uh okay in the old days there was zero
options for a stay-at-home mom but now
there's actually some policies you can
get you might check with uh zander or
one with one of our elps if you're
concerned about it or are curious for
that matter you can get a quote for free
and see what's out there uh
but the there is you can do it it's just
it used to be none zero
so that's the uh that's the issue but
yeah i i think with that small a benefit
18 000 a year you can you can probably
handle it the question is could we
replace this income if she couldn't work
and it sounds like you could easily
replace that 18 grand um if you got
creative started you know work on the
side i don't know what your income is
but this doesn't seem worth a thousand
dollars a month a year in premiums to
cover that benefit yeah that's that's a
good point and uh
but it is a good time for you and i to
stop and say look one of the most
underinsured
areas
of the kinds of insurance you should buy
is long-term disability a lot of people
don't have any
and it's um
and you're actually 12 times more likely
to become disabled than to die by age
65. wow so and everybody gets life
insurance or talks about life insurance
or knows they need life insurance or
whatever but they completely ignore
disability insurance the best place to
get your disability insurance is through
work
if you're working that's where i get it
it's the cheapest uh well we furnish it
free yeah thank you for that by the way
you're welcome appreciate it and free to
you and uh not free to me but yeah we
furnish it because it's not that
expensive when we buy in a huge group
like this
uh and so it's an easy benefit as an
employer for us to provide
uh but even if not if if you can buy it
with the group through work
it's still gonna be probably 25 of what
it'll be in the open market most the
time
so um
if not check with your trade
organization
like your real estate agent check with
the realtors if they have a plan
uh you know the if your home builder the
home builders you know association those
kinds of things uh you know you check
with your trades uh
that's a good way another thing to
remember is
if you are paying for it pay and you
have the option of buying it with after
tax or before tax dollars
buy it with after tax dollars
because that way your disability in your
disability payout if you get it will be
tax-free if you buy it with before tax
dollars your disability uh premium or
your disability payout if it comes to
you will be taxable
so really really important to buy with
after tax dollars one of the few things
we tell you to buy with after tax
dollars yeah it's a good reminder there
eric's with us in lansing eric welcome
to the ramsey show
hi dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
hey so i'm a student at michigan state
and
our administrators have gotten a little
spooked by the omicron variant
and because of that they put the first
three weeks of classes online
now of course they didn't refund any of
the 600 credit tuition
even partially so we're getting online
classes that really aren't as good as in
person but for the full tuition
um and
really it's just kind of
frustrating because there's nothing uh
students can really do about it and so
there's a certain period with most the
time that you can opt out of a class
early in the semester and get your
refund exactly already
kind of
well so it's it's in february and i'm
trying to do a little bit of student
activision before that to get students
to realize hey you don't have to get
yanked around like this you can
disenroll and get a refund on your
tuition yeah i would um
the problem is is that students are
really nervous about doing that because
they're like well what do i do
and so
trying to give students some advice on
where to find internships where to find
a job i took a semester off in 2020 and
worked at the hospital and put 10 000 in
my 401k it was a great time but is there
any advice that you would have for these
students that are like just frankly
scared to kind of make that bold move
yeah it is it's not as bold a move if
you have something to do
uh if you decide i'm gonna go do x i'm
gonna go do y or i'm gonna just uh
transfer to a place that actually has
classes
and uh that school just lost my business
uh because if i wanted to take online i
would have signed up at an online place
you know and that that's okay too if you
want to do that but
i'm not gonna you know pay for the
college experience and and be online i'm
not gonna do it uh
so i i like your idea uh and it's not
just to punish them but there's
marketplace consequences to these policy
decisions for the university
and um and so
i
i don't know if this particular february
it will all come home to roost but i can
promise you this higher ed is
people are looking at higher ed
completely different and a lot of it is
not just the student loans and just the
expenses but they're also looking at
higher ed different because of the uh
and not just because it's getting more
and more expensive but also because of
their reaction to covet and what they've
done to the students and so
uh
you know if i'm if i'm a student there
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go find a job and
i'm gonna i'm gonna take a take a
semester off or i'm gonna trade go to a
school that allows me to go to class and
just take my money and go over there
yeah the worst thing you can do is think
i don't have any options woe is me
instead of using this time intentionally
making some money finding a different
school and i know it can be a pain to
transfer but if the school isn't giving
you any more options other than hey you
can get a refund then you've got to make
a move here yeah and that's uh well and
and they've proven to be undependable
you know that's the thing
this you know we now know who you are we
know how you're going to react in these
situations and so it's revealing a lot
you're probably you're probably going to
do it again and so lots of businesses
and friends
and
family members and we now know who you
are you know and we know how you're
going to react in these situations and
it's just
it's disappointing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today i'm your host dave ramsey
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five barry is in greenville
south carolina hi barry what's up
good afternoon everybody i
over the years have tried to save my
pennies and
we got to the big one
and now i am about to
well i know i am retired i've been
retired 20 years i'm turning 80. oh
no one a penny own a very nice house
we're doing fine but i have no idea how
to produce income with this cash i have
nothing in the market
okay
and you have
the big one you're talking about you've
got a million dollars in cash
yes okay wow way to go so barry how much
money did you inherit are you a
millionaire because of inheritance or
because you're hard work no no i i'm uh
my inheritance is zilch it's hard work
and uh just good common sense and i
gotta hold you guys and
run blue years ago and kind of followed
them and so on and so forth my kids are
all going and gone they've all done
exceedingly well i don't need to leave a
penny to them we and then since my last
kid left
we have always paid 20 percent uh
gross
growth to uh
to giving
good good big heroes but anyhow so here
we are well basically all the money we
have coming in right now i sold to an
apartment i had blah blah blah
and we have social security and i do a
little gig on the side during little cup
money that
it more than covers our
monthly expenses however i want to be
100 retired yeah good for you
well done sir impressive very well done
and uh is there a reason you don't have
any of it in the market
well you know
i was in the market
and i get it went higher and i got
frightened and pulled out and then when
i'll get back in i kept going higher and
higher and higher anyhow big mistake and
now it's up at you know thirty five
thousand ridiculous can't believe it's
just high but i got out way too soon
what were you invested in back in clip
here yeah
oh well i kind of called it a fun by my
last name i was in some real good stuff
okay good i had some really good i i
wish i had never sold it i would have a
heck of a lot more but
right now this is where i am okay all
right good
well what would i do if i woke up in
your shoes is how i answer questions
here
um
i i think i'm going to get really
comfortable with generosity piece which
you already are
i'm going to get really comfortable with
leaving money to kids even if they don't
need it and or leaving it to ministries
or charities that um
that that yeah listen i i know what to
do with it i have no problem there okay
how do i generate some income so i'm not
living just on social security and i
can't do this little gig that i'm doing
what do i do with this money i
personally would put it in the market
i'd go i go
i would sit down with a smart investor
pro and pick out some mutual funds and
let those mutual funds create an income
and i mean you're you're going to create
you know 70 to 100 000 a year in income
off a million dollars invested in mutual
funds
and uh even if you tear into the
principle a little bit systematically in
order to have the income coming in to to
have uh the lifestyle that you want
you've got you've got a figure in mind
that you need coming in
uh and you know i would invest some of
this money to do that uh you don't have
to invest at all you can whatever gives
you a comfort level but
um there's i'm 61 i'm not getting out of
the market i'm going to ride it all the
way in
yeah if you've got nothing that you want
to spend that money on right now i would
be putting as much of it as you could
into the market and working with a
financial advisor is going to help with
that fear that you have of what's going
to happen am i putting my money into
something conservative enough they can
walk you through all of your options
there to make sure that you're
comfortable they want to make sure
you're educated here i do think you need
to maybe sit down with smart investor
pro or someone that can
that you can develop a trust with not a
trust that uh do you do everything they
say automatically but a trust that i
trust their judgment
and so when they're telling me something
i can i can give it serious
consideration
and so if you get freaked out and go oh
the market's too high and you call your
guy or your gal you sit down with them
have a meeting with them a cup of coffee
and go look i'm i'm having that thing
again i'm ready to pull it out again and
then they can talk you off the ledge
because you have a trust level in their
knowledge base uh and they teach you
something that gives you a reason to get
off the ledge yeah instead of just
jumping off because your problem is
you're jumping in and out all the time
and that you told us that you told us
that was your problem so
i that's what i would do with it that or
go buy some real estate whether you just
got out of the apartments something that
creates an income you do something that
goes and creates an income
sounds like you like real estate like i
do so that might be an okay thing very
well done sir congratulations
adam is in houston texas adam welcome to
the ramsay show
thank you sir it's been a pleasure
talking to you today you too what's up
hey um
my name is adam i'm 34 i came to this
blizzard country in 2009.
um
basically my my network is 1.2 million
and i own
five rental properties and one
home which i live in and currently i
have 183 000 in cash
and i have 632 000 in total debt with
all the rentals including my primary
house so i'm just trying right now me
and my wife to
uh slow down and trying to pay down the
debt and we are in a debate right now so
instead of paying down the rentals or
paying down
our house first
so
do you owe money on your personal
residence
yes how much
198. and you have 183 in the bank
yes what's your household income
162.
okay so you got 400 on the rentals and
100 and 200 on your home give or take
uh that's and also including the 18 000
car that's included with 632 000. uh
because i have i use
those credits uh
what they call like monitoring and you
just count how much how many dollars
they owe and it shows the total debt i
have is 632 but it's including 18 000
with my costume do you have car debt
18 000. yeah you need to pay the car off
today and then i would work on paying my
personal residence off and then i would
work on paying the rentals off
okay all right that sounds um that's
what i was talking to my wife was
telling me
we can keep the cash it's there and we
keep adding to it every month if there
is an opportunity we can jump on it if
it's not we just like no there's not an
opportunity the opportunity right now is
get your debt cleaned up
okay and then when you got zero debt
you're gonna have so much cash coming
out your ears then you're gonna see some
opportunities and you're gonna pay cash
for them
from this point forward you have the
opportunity to stabilize this portfolio
that you've grown and if you continue to
go the other direction you're going to
continue to destabilize it and
eventually lose it
yeah
because you like buying real estate and
debt doesn't bother you and it needs to
start bothering you this is going to
catch up with you
yeah
you got here okay and so far you're okay
but it this
and
but you're like the guy who put one
quarter in the slot machine and one and
you think it's going this is gonna work
every time and i've done this a long
time adam and i own a bunch of real
estate and i love real estate
so if you want to you called the ramsey
show and you weren't going to expect to
hear anything except get out of debt and
you also said what's the fastest way i
can get out of my debt and now you're
going yeah but you're saying yeah in a
way that makes me think you're not doing
any of this stuff we're telling you yeah
people tend to get a little starry-eyed
with real estate investing and i just
got a message from a guy yesterday on
instagram who lost his shirt with this
he got a little excited about real
estate investing did it before he was
ready and he ended up losing a ton of
money and so i was trying to help him
clean up this mess and i don't think
adam's going to go there today yeah i
don't think that's the issue but but
what the issue is with adam is uh when
he says stuff like well i've got this
money set aside for an opportunity
translation i'm getting ready to go buy
more real estate on debt
okay and um as soon as i see something i
like you know and right now is not a
good time to buy real estate anyway it's
a great time to sell it great time to
pay off your debt though amen and amen
always a good day for that amen hey
thanks for the call brother that puts us
hour the ramsey show in the books austin
is on the phones james childs is our
producer george campbell is my co-host i
am dave ramsey your host and we'll be
back with you before you know
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america we're glad you're
here george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host as we take your calls
about your work your relationships your
money you and how all of these revolve
together
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five gen starts off
this hour in san antonio
hi jen how are you
i am better than i deserve dave
good
happy new year how can we help
yes sir my husband and i are um
we're army we have an 18 year old who
will be joining the army uh he's going
to be leaving for bct in june he's a
senior in high school right now and he's
18. and i want to set him up um
i want to set him up you know
financially with a good base my husband
and i have both been through fpu we
graduated we are debt-free
we had 97 000 of debt
we got rid of it in three years on
specialist pay and that was
not a lot of money and i was still a
stay-at-home mom
um
my question for you for the 18 year old
is should we sign him up for fpu
fpu military or foundations because he's
still a senior in high school
probably military
um okay or just regular fpu either one
but this is an adult doing adult stuff
and you're preparing for him for that
how much of your story does he
understand
um
i'm pretty sure that he
doesn't really remember a whole lot of
it he was a little kid when we were
grunting through all of it
is he working or has he worked in high
school at all
he does have a job now he's not making a
whole lot but he does have a job right
now
he does have
minor
expenses
i am making him the car that he is
driving is a an old beater that we uh
just never got rid of we paid cash for
it we never got rid of it
and uh so we're just passing it along to
all the kids and his uh responsibility
is to pay insurance and gas for that
good
i think you're in a unique position for
for two reasons one is uh your debt
story and two is your military story
thank you for your service and i thank
you for your support yeah and i think
you sit down with him you and your
husband uh you might even um
the two of you take him to dinner
somewhere
nice and uh you know to celebrate him
going into the military and to celebrate
him moving into manhood
and so forth
and uh and during that dinner i would do
two things uh number one i i i would
convince him of your i'd convince him of
your position
using two things one is
we've been in the military all these
years and let me tell you here's from a
military person's perspective that is
uh experienced
not brand new here's what all the stupid
people do when they're 18 and they go to
boot camp because there is stupid all
over that
right
oh you wouldn't believe it oh i do
believe we work with the military that
goes to post yeah it's it's when you
leave the base and they're stupid down
both sides of the road for about two
miles
and so uh you know that that's the thing
and so you know you need to just talk
him through that military as an older
military person with experience
and then on top of that you say now you
don't probably don't remember it but
here's our story when you were a little
kid
and here's what we did and this is how
important this stuff is so
we've gotten you this financial peace
university military financial peace
university and uh we want to uh insulate
you
against stupid by giving you this
information
so that you don't go out and repeat what
most people do and even a little bit of
what we did
yeah
and and i think i think that's a uh you
know what most people that are 18 and go
to boot camp do they do all these dumb
things
we know that as military people we also
know that this debt thing is this
because we did it and this is how we got
out and you don't remember the strain
you were a little guy you don't remember
the grunt you were a little guy and uh
and i you know this is
mom and dad as adults talking to their
adult kid this is your oldest isn't it
yes yeah this is a whole new phase for
you guys to learn to have friends to
become friends with your adult kids and
advise them from the friend seat instead
of the mom seat
and that's kind of what i'm recommending
here you're you're building credit let's
pretend this was not your kid that it
was your friend's kid
and you took them to dinner that's how
you you would persuade them
you would not be able to use your mom
voice
right
yes
and that that's that's that's a new
skill you got to develop anyway because
he's getting ready to be out of your
control in about 20 more minutes
yeah i feel like there's a little bit of
fear here of i hope my kid makes good
decisions and it sounds like he has
incredible parents so i'm less worried
about that but i do want him to avoid
all these traps and going through
something like financial peace
university is is a great way to do that
and i would love to gift that to him uh
we can gift him with a ramsay plus
membership austin will pick up and make
that happen for him and you tell him
this is from dave and george and they
said the only stipulation is you have to
actually do it yeah amen
good stuff yeah hang on and uh austin
pick up yeah george i did that exact
same thing but from a civilian
perspective when the kids are getting
ready to go to college you know we had a
a right of passage moment
that says you know we have trained you
in how to walk with god we've trained
you in how to be a confident young woman
a young man
uh we have trained you now we and here's
what people do when they go to college
you know they're dumb
they play beer pong instead of going to
class
you know and there's a high correlation
between people that attend class and
they graduate
and there's a high correlation between
people that look at the list of classes
you have to take to graduate
in four years and actually take those
classes and then you will magically
graduate in four years it's an amazing
thing
so you're helping them warn them about
hey here's what you're gonna see
yeah avoid this yeah you're gonna see
people do things that you never dreamed
that people would ever do and you're
gonna see them do it right there in
front of you
and then you got to decide who you are
before you get in that situation and so
you kind of set them up
you know we have the the rite of passage
conversation
that is insulating or ensuring
uh that this is what's coming and here's
how you're going to deal with it or you
know you're you're going to be in a and
i'm
you know a a mainstream school
uh not everybody there is going to share
your religious views or your faith and
so you're going to have to act you're to
be a representative of that
you know ramses just don't act like that
ramsay's act like this
and you know that because you had to do
that well under our watchful eye while
you were a teenager but now you got to
make that other move and that's just a
really good thing that parents um
need to plug in and do it's a a powerful
thing i gathered about 15 20 guys on my
back porch
and uh had all of them give my son
advice before he left wow he'll never
forget that strong men good men men that
were successful that he looked up to and
it worked and man that advice that if we
put it on a dvd and stored it it was
pretty incredible
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much pure
talk gives you the same great 5g
coverage on the same 5g network as one
of the big guys for half the cost the
average family saves over 800 a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
next week is a big week at
the new baby steps millionaire book
comes out
on tuesday if you haven't pre-ordered
yours you should now at
ramseysolutions.com for 20 to get your
deal
it's got about 100 worth of add-ons all
of that stuff goes away on tuesday when
the book comes out so now's your time to
get that as quickly as you can
and we are doing a live stream event
called building wealth in 2022. the
in-person tickets over 1500 of them are
sold out they sold out in just a matter
of days when we opened up the event so
now we've opened it up to a free live
stream over 70 000 folks have registered
so far
which means that there'll be over a
hundred thousand viewing it at least
and you don't want to miss this george
campbell beside me here rachel cruz
ramsey personality best-selling author
will be with me to tell you how to build
wealth in
2022. we're going to deal with all the
discussion of all the stuff everybody's
talking about out there and get rich
quick is alive and well right now
and
i've been thinking about that a lot and
you know got some things to say about it
so you don't want to miss this
and you don't want to miss the steps to
really
building wealth we're really really
really going to show you how to really
become wealthy and yes more than 10 000
people have become millionaires
doing the baby steps millionaire stuff
so we actually do know what we're
talking about dave ramsey's only again
for getting out of debt you're an idiot
okay
dave ramsey's led more people into
millionaire status than anybody else
walking right now boom so that's mic
drop all right so let's just talk about
it for real here and quit dealing with
your dad jokes and your boomer jokes and
all the other bs some of you reddit
threads have got going um
so
we're actually going to address this
stuff head on and some of you are not
going to like what we say but we're
going to tell you the truth
that's the way it always is around here
because we love you and we want you to
win
ramsey solutions dot com slash wealth to
register for free
to watch the live stream thursday the
13th this thursday
coming a week from yesterday for most of
you
uh the 13th next week on thursday at
seven o'clock in the evening
central time a free
live stream
but you do have to pre-register to be
able to get it for free just go to
ramseysolutions.com
wealth georgia it's going to be great
i'm really excited next week is a big
week for a lot of reasons dave you've
got the book launch on the 11th we have
the event on the 13th and i'm going to
tease something else happening on the
12th okay and that is my debt free
scream
i'm going to let the cat out of the bag
if you're listening right now to tune in
third hour
debt free scream from the camels so i'm
really excited i'm i'm kind of nervous
my wife's freaking out friday
it's on the 12th it's on wednesday so we
got the book lunch on tuesday i'll be
hosting the show with you on wednesday
and we're gonna do the day and you're
gonna have to get up out of this chair
and go out and do your debt first take a
break and go do the scream okay and then
be back on the air a little weird and
then we have the event on thursday so
it's gonna be a packed week yeah it's a
big week and a lot of stuff so george
and rachel and i on thursday night don't
miss this ramsay solutions.com
wealth it is a free
live stream no salesman will call randy
is with us in toronto canada hi randy
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
hey so me and my wife are almost
finished here with baby step three and
we're gonna get ready to start investing
for retirement this year
uh since we're living in canada
i was wondering how much u.s funds we
should hold in our retirement accounts
as opposed to a canadian fund
i don't know um
i would think i mean you you have uh the
equivalent of 401k systems there correct
we do we do have the equivalent of uh
roth ira here
but it's very popular for canadians to
hold u.s based funds because the u.s
market is so much bigger than the
canadian market are you allowed to do
that inside of your retirement plan
yes
why wouldn't you then just put it in
whatever's best
if the us-based funds are performing
better than the canadian funds fine if
their canadian funds are performing
better than the us then put it in the
canadian
this is not a uh this is not a
nationalist issue it's not a it's not a
patriotic issue it's a math thing
right
so where are you gonna make the most
money
i mean i'll put it in germany funds i
don't care i mean i you know where's it
gonna make the most money
and um i mean i might have some moral
objection to china but i don't you know
most anybody else so
uh uh you know you've got to look at
those kinds of things but but but you
know
if you've got access to them and you've
got the tax protection i don't know much
about the canadian system other than i
know you do have that
the equivalent of a roth going there um
and and um so yeah you do your 40 your
version of a 401k roth there and if you
can you fund it with the best funds that
are available yeah and as long as you're
diversifying that across the four types
you know growth growth and income
aggressive growth international you're
going to be diversified all over the
world anyways but like dave saying
canada's economy it's a small part of
the world so there's nothing wrong with
going all in on u.s stocks if that's
what is best for your mutual funds so
there's no issue with you investing in
u.s stocks make sure you're working with
a tax professional 401k and it's tax
advantaged that's always going to be the
best route to go
yeah and you know the four mutual funds
we suggest for the u.s
listeners is growth growth and income
aggressive growth and
international
thus the companies that the
international funds it might be a u.s
fund but it's investing in
international companies the stocks are
the companies are international so yeah
that's what we're looking for is the
best rates of return john is in columbia
missouri hi john welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so i recently sold my car it was paid
off
um and it made about ten thousand
dollars in profit
um
i had planned on taking that um it's
thirty four thousand dollars in savings
and paying off my only debt which is
um a twenty eight thousand dollar
student loans
um but i'm worried about the taxes
uh i know that's kind of an unusual
unusual situation so i've never heard of
making that much money on a car sale
should i put some of this sold the car
for 10 000 more than you paid for it
um 9
200
9750 to be exact yes
holy crud
that's awesome
it was a 2019 camry
and it sold for nine thousand dollars
more than you paid for it
nine thousand seven hundred and fifty
yeah yeah you covered that yeah i got it
i'm just i'm just so you paid cash for
this car and then you resold it a few
months later a year later
no it was uh may will be two years
okay
wow
i never thought i would be answering a
capital gains question on a car in my
life
but uh apparently you're going to pay 15
of that so you need to set aside 1500
bucks
for your taxes because you're going to
have that as extra taxes or you need to
have that much extra taken out of your
check throughout the year one of the two
because you just created a taxable event
and if it's the asset was held longer
than one year so it should be subject to
capital gains i guess
god i never thought i'd answer this
question on a depreciating asset but um
that's just bizarre that's where we find
ourselves um so wonderful it's wonderful
good for you so now you got to pay taxes
on it and then what was your net what
are you going to be driving
so i have a better car and i work remote
so i
i work from home so um i also have
access to a family car but i have a
beater that i planned on driving until
i figured something but so you have 34
000 and you have how much in your
account
34 000 in my checking account okay
savings and your all your debt is 28.
yep student loans wonderful pay it off
okay
you still got six
even with a 1500 tax bill coming up and
the 1500 tax bill is only is 14 months
away
okay if i contribute to my
if i contribute to my retirement
could i bring it down that way
yeah i wouldn't worry about the taxes
i'd just be going
i just experienced a unicorn moment i
made money on a car
i i i'm
i'd just be so happy i did that i'd pay
some taxes i really i know i wouldn't
try to worry about the tax limiting the
tax burden let's just go be smart
wow
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in chicago carly's calling
and it says on my screen you're debt
free congratulations carly
thank you very much so how much have you
paid off
i have paid off 68 000
good for you and how long did that take
it took me five years good for you and
your range of income during that five
years um started with about 65 grand was
my income then when i started and now
it's 96 000. cool what do you do for a
living
i am an architect
what kind of debt was the 68 000
it was my student debt all right
all right
so why did it take you five years to do
this wow well that seems like it took a
long time
it did take a long time i i live by
myself um in the city of chicago it's
not the cheapest city to live in and do
this on my own
so um but i chipped away and just kept
at it and um you know in it i stepped
back getting a you know smaller
apartment
um not as much so did what i could i had
to buy a car um cash um in the process
so and then with kovid i'm not making
overtime uh that's why it played into
not paying off as quickly as i would
have liked um all right praise the lord
it's done the good news is you stayed
with it you because i mean you that's
pretty incredible you you just kept
chipping away
yeah they kept chipping away that's
right were the student loans the only
debt
um there was credit card debt as well as
um some medical ah
okay a little bit of everything there so
a little bit of everything what got you
on this journey five years ago how did
you get connected to us
sure my older brother and his wife they
got married 10 years ago and in that
process of getting married they went
into it debt-free paid for their wedding
cash and it just was a huge inspiration
my brother um then led classes at his
church um with the dave ramsey approach
and the baby steps and um i went to him
and i was like i need some help with you
know just seeing the mountain of death
that i had and i was like i do not want
to continue to have this um you know as
a shadow behind me and over me so how
can i get on it so he he helped me and
through obviously the steps that dave
ramsey has laid out so wow that's really
cool good for you carly
yeah it's rare that that works where you
lead by example and and you went yeah i
want to know how to do that
and show me the way you were willing to
take that ready
exactly now today you're leading by
example by sharing your story with
everybody else what do you tell what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is
uh stay with it
um and be disciplined
um and make a budget
okay very cool good for you
how's it feel how's it feel to be free
it's you know now i i paid off my last
student loan um in november and it has
now hit me where in my budget i'm seeing
all that go into savings and it's
it's remarkable and i give all the glory
to the lord um it's it's now it's
hitting me of just like wow i don't have
to worry about any of those payments
anymore so
very very cool yeah very cool well done
kiddo
well done i'm proud of you i'm guessing
your brother was cheering you along all
the way
he was he was my first call after i paid
my last payment in november that's right
how old are you
um i'm i will be 40 in april awesome and
not a payment in the world making 96 000
life is good that's right thank you good
job really good job very proud of you
very proud of you great work great work
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you coming that'll be
the
next chapter in your story for sure how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth and how you can too and we'll
send that on out to you and also send
you a copy of the total money makeover
that you can give away to someone and
interrupt their process like your
brother did for you
thank you very much good job carly all
right carly in chicago 68 000
paid off in five years making 65-96
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
i've been free
yeah
[Applause]
well done
man that's incredible i'm so proud of
you
janelle is in cleveland hi janelle
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi george can you hear me okay
absolutely what's up
um
my husband and i are 65
and our kids are 32 and 30
and
i don't know when to tell them
how much money we have
now
now
um
well the only reason i'm hesitating is
because it's
1.5 million
yeah
so are they are they are they
misbehaving
oh no
no
why do you why do you think this
knowledge will bring harm
um probably the way i grew up
i didn't know
anything about my parents finances until
i was
gosh probably
my dad died 55 maybe i mean my parents
just never talked about it i never asked
them right
um yeah lots of parents don't talk about
money or sex and then when their
children grow up they're surprised to
find out they had both
well they're both married and my
daughter is having a baby in about three
days so i think she knows about sex
one down one to go i wasn't talking
about her sex i was talking about yours
but yeah i know
oh my gosh yeah i i think you sit down
now
you know when i had this conversation
with ours they were uh just coming out
of college
i didn't want them i wanted them to have
the maturity to be able to handle the
discussion the emotional and the
spiritual maturity and uh we're a family
of faith and so the conversation started
with this as for me and my house we
serve the lord
and so the information i'm getting ready
to explain to you is not
uh is not you hitting the lottery
because you are not inheriting the money
you're inheriting the responsibility to
manage the money for god
and that's how we started the discussion
and that's still how we have the
discussion to this day they've yet to
inherit any money but
but
they know they know what our wealth is
in detail and they know exactly what's
going to happen to every penny of it uh
we have a big meeting once a year with
our leadership team at our office and
with our kids and we go over the real
every piece of real estate we go over
uh you know any of the wealth that is
there and exactly how the we'll remind
everybody how the wheels and the trusts
all work because it's kind of
complicated
and um you know we just have a review of
this and this is a transaction
so long ago they got past the emotions
of feeling like they hit the lottery
well i guess i'm wondering why why why
do i
what's the purpose in it because you can
teach them
to have the proper spiritual and
financial stance on this while you're
alive
otherwise you don't know what the
reaction is going to be and if you get a
negative reaction you may want to adjust
some of your inheritance
um
okay
because we
yeah we don't leave money to people in
our family if they're misbehaving
because we don't want to finance
misbehavior with god's money oh no
no i wouldn't do that i know but how
about their
how about their son-in-laws or our
son-in-law the same thing
listen if it's going to affect the if
the information that this money is there
is going to affect them how much more do
you think the money's going to actually
affect them
when it comes out of left field
and there's no time to emotionally
process it oh by the way we're also
processing the death of a loved one at
the same time
hmm
so the so you think the son-in-law
should be included in absolutely
they are at my house
because they may they're they're they're
family
they're not necessarily going to
actually personally get the money but
their spouse is
and so you dadgum right and you get to
speak to all of them
about what this means to you and and how
we you think they ought to view this and
that we're not going to allow you to
feel like you can put co push the car up
into neutral because this is coming you
know we can have all kinds of good
discussions it's all kinds of teachable
moments
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 16 8
better is a little with righteousness
than great revenues with injustice
mother teresa said it is not how much we
give but how much we love
we put into
giving but how much love we put into
giving that's it say it backward
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
jackie is with us in houston texas hi
jackie what's up
hi dave thank you for answering my call
sure
what's going on
hello hello what's going on
yes i would like to know if we should
sell our truck
all right uh how much do you owe on it
uh it's 28
600 and i got an offer for 41 000
something from the dealer wow
and what's your household income
it's about um 90 000
and how much how much other debt do you
have
81 000
yes i would sell it
i would sell it you know why
let me give you the let me give you how
the tools i use to make that decision
that quickly
okay tool number one is
you would never want to own because cars
go down in value until the last three
months
uh and
they go down in value you don't want to
own things with wheels and motors that
total up to more than half your annual
income
and yours do when we put your other car
with it
uh and that's rule number one rule
number two is can i be debt free not
counting my house inside of two years
and keep the car if we love the car
uh in your case you could be driving a 9
000 car after you sell this
pretty easily have no car payments and
be able to work on the rest of this debt
and be done and so i would get rid of it
what do you think george i'm in the same
boat i'm usually if i'm a fan of selling
especially in this market when you can
get that much for a truck 41 grand they
just write you a check and you're you
know you're out of this debt and you can
tackle this next debt and you can
upgrade in car later this is not a
forever thing so i know it's not going
to be fun to drive around in your 9 000
car but it's not forever you're gonna be
out of debt in 18 to 24 months you've
got 90k income there and you had what 83
000 left on the debt so you could pay
that off in two years
yes um yeah basically i'm making like 12
000 if they sell it because they only
have twenty thousand left on that truck
right
we're actually thinking selling it so i
can like um put a big snowball on yeah
buy you about a ten thousand dollar car
and put a couple thousand dollars
towards the death snowball
and then just attack but the big thing
is you got rid of this huge payment
and it's thirty thousand dollars or
twenty nine thousand dollars of your
eighty
is that uh outside of the eight we have
two cars we actually have two old cars
oh so you've got another car you can
drive and throw the whole 10 000 or 12
000 at it yeah on top of getting rid of
29.
but is the 29 000 debt included in the
80 number
yes okay oh great yeah so now we're down
to 50 minus 10 we're down to 40. we cut
your debt in half
in a year
yeah and we're gonna have another 3 000
cash coming in so
um so throwing that into that too so
basically gonna finish the first yeah
the first 49 000 soon if if i saw this
truck i i would sell it i'm excited for
you guys this is awesome congratulations
very cool here's the thing it's a stupid
truck
you can get another stupid truck i've
had a lot of stupid trucks i like stupid
trucks you got a smart truck now though
it's a stupid truck it's all true
they're all going down in value it's a
wonderful truck it's a raptor and i love
my truck but but it's not the uh it's
not a you know it i can get another one
i can get another one
you can get another one you know it's
not you we we treat cars like somehow
the like they're chis like like they're
a diamond and you can't you know there's
there's only one and you can't get
another one they're everywhere you can
get your other car i mean
people get really sentimental over their
vehicles well now we because it's a
large purchase we act like
it's harder to get in and out of them
in and out of a deal than it is all you
do is just go buy one i mean it's not
it's an hour of your time go buy another
one you know and get rid of that one
it's not it's not that big a thing so
uh you know the only thing you got is
the licensing and transfer fees and that
kind of stuff that'll get you but but
you know so you don't want to be jumping
in and out every two months but
i you know i bought a i bought a car a
truck um man
dumb i i kind of impulsed it i liked it
i went on it had these loud mufflers on
redneck i loved it was this back in the
day or was this no this is not that long
ago uh three or four years ago okay and
uh i just
found the truck i like i just bought it
and um
traded a raptor i had at that time in on
it
or i sold the raptor or whatever i did
and then i didn't like the truck
and i'm driving this thing for like six
or eight months
and every time i got in i didn't like
the truck i hated it and i finally went
ramsay you're an idiot
sold truck you don't like it it's just a
truck you're not stuck so i sold it and
i got another raptor now i'm happy again
you know i mean it's just not
you're just not stuck in these things
you can you can you know you've been
driving that honda for five fifty five
thousand years it feels like it that
honda needs to go the bumper's hanging
off dave i'd be embarrassed if you saw
it you got more invested in your french
bulldog than you doing that's true when
your french bulldog is worth more than
your civic you know you're a hipster
there it is
you might be a hipster if that's your
french bulldog calls your designer dog
costs more than your car is worth more
than your car your dog shouldn't be more
than one quarter of your car should not
be one more
foreigners and principals thanks to me
yeah that that's yeah whole new whole
new hipster principles but yeah that's
the same thing it's time we were we've
been talking off here he's getting a new
car that's why i can but
i can kid him about it y'all don't say
i'm not shaming george no george is
easily not easily shamed by the way when
you have no shame it's hard to do
george is he he's he's riding that
rocking that honda with great
but but doing that free scream next week
that's right you'll see one of my my
priorities we'll see we'll see what
happens here
got a debt-free honda a debt-free
bulldog
and a debt-free everything
and we're going to talk about that next
week it's going to be a big week so
uh in the middle of all that we can get
uh
we're going to have to find georgia car
yep i'm hoping dave will just get sick
are you going to buy me one i like where
this is going i i didn't there was no
intention of that at all i think i was
just asking simply what kind of car you
like i'm also not going to buy you a dog
so boring and pragmatic i'll probably
just get a nicer newer honda that's the
truth
george i know
i just don't understand cars dave i
didn't grow up you don't have a thing
for them you know it's not like a car
that gives you a little exciting little
zip that i've been in enough fender
benders that you know that are my fault
that i'm less excited about getting a
shiny new car
so your lack of confidence in your
driving ability has dissuaded you from
getting a good it's my wife's lack of
confidence oh
now we're getting to it yep we need dr
deloney in here because we're turning
into an aquarium
on the phone oh we got to dissect this
here
all right so yeah we're going to work on
this uh george we're gonna have to think
about what kind of car what would george
look good in ooh like a monster truck i
think if i get anything that's lifted as
high as you can lift it up i want a step
a little step ladder to get up in it
yeah i want to climb up into that truck
little ladder that rolls out those
little rope ladder things that roll out
yep with an under light led kit you know
just perfect lights oh definitely like
the change while you drive yep yeah
that's you george i mean at this point
i'm probably i deserve a clown car just
the smallest you know little probably
not like a prius no no like john delaney
oh george no no no no okay you care
about me too much don't let me drive a
prius friends don't let friends drop
pieces yeah this is no i george you need
like a real car all right you might be a
tesla guy though you might be a cool
tesla but i mean rachel's a cool tesla
girl i'm not i'm not cool enough for a
tesla the price point on the tesla still
feels steep for for what you're getting
okay that's how i feel about it spending
50 grand on a tesla i don't know okay
the roi and the electric saving and then
having a stop on a road trip well you
know that part stresses but the good
news is you could plug in here at the
building and i'll pay for your fuel
that's right fun fact if you work at
ramsey solutions we've got electric
spots ready for you and i don't have any
gas tanks out here for the rest of us
that get burned gas so there's this is
this is
uh it's unfair i'm not treating
employees the same i should probably be
sued for that
oh wait give it time
too soon
too soon yeah all right there there's
tiny one of our team members driving his
tesla out there he's cheering saying
thanks dave for the free free uh i
thought tiny was driving a truck he's
got both tiny drives a tesla a guy named
tiny drives a tesla
think about that it'll come to you okay
ah well that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books george campbell
ramsey personality my co-host james and
austin in the booth i am dave ramsey
your host we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
you